PETE: WE'RE BACK WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT, PART THREE OF THE TWITTER
FILE IFS REVEALING EXECUTIVES
MET WITH THE FBI AND DHS AND DNI
ON A WEEKLY BASIS AROUND THE
2020 ELECTION.
LAOS LEAST WEEKLY BASIS IS.
IN A SERIES OF TWEETS, MATT
TAIBBI WRITE NICK NICHOLS IS
ASKED IF THE MARKETING
DEPARTMENT SHOULD SAY TWITTER
REPORTS MISINFORMATION WITH
OUTSIDE EXPERTS.
WILL: PICKLES TOLD THEM TO SAY
PARTNERSHIPS, NOT SURE WE
DESCRIBE THE DHS AND FBI AS
EXPERTS, IT READS, QUOTE.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR SOME WAY TO
CHARACTERIZE THEIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT, AND
UNFILTERED'S DAN BONN GEE GLOW
IS A GREAT -- BONGINO.
YOU WERE ONE OF THE PEOPLE
PLACED ON TWITTER'S BLACKLIST TO
THEIR SEARCH ENGINE.
GOOD MORNING, DAN.
HOW WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE THAT
RELATIONSHIP?
>> LISTEN, THIS IS ONLY THE
BIGGEST FIRST AMENDMENT SCANDAL
OF MY LIFETIMEMENT YOU KNOW, I
JUST TURNED 48 NOT THAT LONG
AGO.
I'VE NEVER SEEN -- AND HERE'S
THE CRAZY THING, GUYS, IT'S SO
EASY TO EXPLAIN THAT IT'S
HILARIOUS WATCHING LIBERAL MEDIA
ACTIVISTS, YOU KNOW, WET THEIR
DIAPERS TRYING TO DEFEND THIS.
FIRST, REMEMBER THE STORY OVER
THE TWITTER GOVERNMENT COLLUSION
TO SUPPRESS PEOPLE LIKE ME AND
SHADOW BAN ME?
THE FIRST STORY WAS, WELK
LISTEN, IT'S A PRIVATE COMPANY,
THERE'S NO GOVERNMENT
INVOLVEMENT.
AND THEN WE FOUND OUT THAT THERE
WAS GOVERNMENT INVOLVEMENT, THAT
THE FBI MAY HAVE BEEN INVOLVED.
AND THEN WE WERE CONFIRMED THAT
THE FBI WAS INVOLVED, AND THEN
THEY WERE LIKE, WELL, THE FBI
WAS JUST GIVING GENERAL WARNINGS
TO TECH COMPANY.
AND THEN IT TURNED OUT THAT IT
WAS FBI AND THE DNI AND THE DHS
AND POTENTIALLY THE CDC AND
OTHERS.
AND THEN THEY WERE LIKE, OKAY,
IT WAS JUST A LOT OF GENERAL
VOICE FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
AND THEN -- SORRY, ONE MORE --
THEN THE STORY MORPHED AGAIN.
THE TWITTER THE EXECUTIVE'S
SWORN STATEMENT TO THE FEC CAME
OUT WHERE HE ADMITTED THAT IT
WASN'T A GENERAL WARNING, BUT
THAT THESE ENTITIES HAD WARNED
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE HUNTER
BIDEN STORY.
AND NOW IF ALL OF A SUDDEN
THEY'RE, LIKE, WELL, SCREW IT,
WE'RE JUST COMMIES, LET'S JUST
ADMIT IT AND CUT THE B.S --
[LAUGHTER]
I MEAN, REALLY.
GUYS, CAN ANYONE ON THE COUCH, I
KNOW YOU'RE ALL STRONG,
LIBERTY-LOVING PATRIOTS.
CAN ANYONE EXPLAIN TO ME HOW THE
FBI, THE DNI AND THE DHS MEETING
WITH A PRIVATE COMPANY AND
WINKING AND NODDING, SUGGESTING
THEY'D RESTRICT PEOPLE'S FREE
SPEECH, CAN YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN
TO ME HOW THAT'S NOT A VIOLATION
OF THE FIRST A AMENDMENT?
I'M ALL EARS, MAN.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE WE'RE EVEN
HAVING DEBATE.
LISA: WELL, THE MEDIA'S IGNORING
IT OUTSIDE OF US.
WE'RE COVERING IT, BUT THE
MEDIA'S IGNORING IT.
HOW DEEP DO YOU THINK THIS GOES,
DAN?
>> WELL, LISTEN, THIS IS THE
NEXT SHOE TO DROP HERE.
SO ON MY SHOW TONIGHT I HAVE AN
"UNFILTERED," IT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE AN 8-MINUTE MONOLOGUE, I HI
PETE MAY HAVE HEARD SOME OF IT,
IT TURNED INTO, LIKE, A
13-MINUTE MONOLOGUE.
IT'S COMPLETELY UNSCRIPTED, AND
IT REALLY SCREWED UP MY WHOLE
SHOW BECAUSE WE HAD TO CANCEL
SOME GUESTS.
I PRODUCE THE RECEIPTS AND THE
FACTS TO TONIGHT.
IT'S NOT JUST THAT THEY COLLUDED
WITH THE GOVERNMENT TO RESTRICT
FREE SPEECH.
WE KNOW THAT.
WE'RE NOT ARGUING ABOUT THAT,
MEDIA IMBECILES, YOU GUYS ARE
JUST USELESS ANYWAY, WE'LL TAKE
THIS FROM HERE.
THE NEXT SHOE TO DROP IS WERE
THESE TECH COMPANIES COLLUDING
WITH EACH OTHER.
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHY I BRING
THIS UP, AND I PRODUCE THE
REAMENDMENT TOES TONIGHT ON MY
SHOW -- RECEIPTS.
I WAS ATTACKED, WELL, I DON'T
WANT TO BE DRAMATIC.
I WAS CONFRONTED BY A LOT OF
THESE TECH COMPANIES, LET'S SAY,
ALL AROUND THE SAME TIME ON MY
PODCAST AND EVERYWHERE ELSE.
AND THEY ALL SEEMED TO HAVE THE
SAME MESSAGE.
NOW, I CAN'T PROVE THEY WERE
COLLUDING WITH EACH OTHER, BUT
I'LL SHOW YOU TONIGHT HOW
GOOGLE, HOW YouTUBE -- WHICH
IS PART OF GOOGLE -- FACEBOOK
AND TWITTER ALL IN THIS SAME
TIME PERIOD ALL CAME AFTER
LITTLE OLD DAN BONGINO FROM
QUEENS.
YouTUBE BANNED ME FOR SAYING
THAT CLOTH MASKS DON'T STOP THE
SPREAD OF COVID WHICH NOW, BY
THE WAY, IS SCIENTIFIC FACT.
GOOGLE ADS WIPE WHOD MY WEB SITE
OFF THEIR -- WIPED MY WEB SITE
OFF THEIR NETWORK.
TWITTER SUSPENDED ME AFTER
JANUARY 6TH FOR SIMPLY
RETWEETING TRUMP'S STATEMENT.
AND THEN FACEBOOK SAYS AT THE
SAME TIME, OH, WE'RE GOING TO
START THE CRUSHING POLITICAL
CONTENT, AND WHO IS IT GOING TO
AFFECT?
I EVEN SHOW YOU THE NEWS MEDIA,
IT SAYS BEN SHAPIRO AND DAN
BONGINO BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
BIGGEST FACEBOOK PAGES IN THE
CONSERVATIVE SPACE.
WERE THEY COLLUDING WITH EACH
OTHER?
I THINK THEY WERE.
PETE: GO AHEAD.
WILL: IF I COULD, I WAS THINKING
ABOUT DAN'S QUESTION TO US, AND
I WANTED TO, OF HOW THEY SAY NOT
A FIRST AMENDMENT VIOLATION.
LIKE YOU, DAN, I LOVE DEBATING.
THAT MEANS I SEEK OUT THE OTHER
SIDE.
HOW ARE THEY SAYING IT,
INCREASING HI IN THIS --
INCREASINGLY IN THIS STORY, HOW
ARE THEY SPINNING IT.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING OTHER THAN THAT IT'S A
NOTHING BURGER, THEY'RE SAYING,
WELL, THE FBI CAN MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PRIVATE
COMPANY, THEY CAN MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT THEY
BELIEVE IS MISINFORMATION.
AND THEN I THINK WE MOVE TO THE
NEXT STEP WHICH IS IF ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FLOW IN ONE
DIRECTION, WHAT DOES THAT TELL
US ABOUT OUR NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE APPARATUS, RIGHT?
WHAT DOES THAT TELL US ABOUT
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS WHICH WE
INCREASINGLY FOCUS ON AND NEED
TO AND THEIR POINT OF VIEW WHEN
IT COMES TO SOMEONE LIKE YOU,
SOMEBODY LIKE ME, SOMEBODY LIKE
METE, LISA AND OUR -- PETE, LISA
AND OUR POINTS OF VIEW?
>> YOU'RE A LAWYER, AND SO YOU
PROBABLY GET THIS.
I'M NOT, BUT I'M INTIMATELY
FAMILIAR WITH HOW THE LAW WORKS
HAVING SPENT MY CAREER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THE REASON WE HAVE JUDGES
BECAUSE, AS YOU KNOW, WILL, THE
LAW'S A LOT OF GRAY AREA.
SO, YES, THEY COULD TECHNICALLY
SAY, OH, WE JUST WINKED AND
NODDED AND SAY, OH, THIS TWEET
DAN BONGINO PUT OUT WILL THE
ABOUT MASKS, THIS COULD BE
CLASSIFIED AS MISINFORMATION.
AND THEN THE FBI COULD SIT BACK
AND SAY WE DIDN'T COMMAND
ANYTHING AND PLAY A EUPHEMISMS
GAME.
BUT, WILL, NO JUDGE IS GOING TO
TAKE THAT SERIOUSLY.
THERE'S AN IMPLIED FORCE
MECHANISM WITH GOVERNMENT THAT
DOESN'T EXIST WHEN A PRIVATE
ENTITY DOES THAT.
THE GOVERNMENT IS THE ONLY
ENTITY IN THE UNITED STATES, IN
OUR COUNTRY THAT HAS THE POWER
TO TALK YOUR LIFE AND YOUR
FREEDOM.
WE DON'T HAVE MERCENARIES, WE
DON'T HAVE PRIVATE POLICE THAT
ARE DEPUTIZED BY THE GOVERNMENT.
YOU MAY HAVE SOME KIND OF POLICE
POWERS, BUT THE GOVERNMENT
SANCTIONS THAT ALL THE.
TIME.
SO WHEN THE FBI MAKES A
RECOMMENDATION,ST IT'S THE NOT A
RECOMMENDATION.
IT'S AN IMPLIED YOU BETTER DO
THIS OR ELSE.
AND ANY SERIOUS JUDGE KNOWS
THAT.
WILL: HEY, BY THE WAY, DAN, I'M
SORRY, THIS WAS HAPPENING AT THE
SAME TIME DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS
WERE THREATENING BIG TECH.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
>> YES, OPENLY.
WILL: DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS
WERE THREATENING BIG TECH WHILE
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT ARMS WERE
MAKING SUGGESTIONS.
>> WILL, I WAS, I WAS AN EARLY
INVESTOR IN PARLER.
AOC LITERALLY TWEETED OUT TO
AMAZON ABOUT THEIR CLOUD WHICH
PARLER WAS ON, HEY, AMAZON, WHAT
ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO DO ABOUT
PARLER?
I MEAN, NOW TO THE LIBS, I KNOW
YOU'RE NOT THAT BRIGHT FINISH.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT LET'S REVERSE THIS.
LISA: I DON'T DISAGREE.
>> THEY'RE NOT.
IMAGINE YOU HAD SAID TO THE
PRO-ABORTION CROWD THAT THE FBI
B WENT INTO A PRO-LIFE GROUP AND
SAID, HEY, GUYS, WE'RE NOT
RECOMMENDING YOU BLOCK AN
ABORTION CLINIC, BUT, YOU KNOW,
IF YOU DID IT, WE MAY NOT DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT SO, YOU KNOW,
IF YOU GUYS GO AND BLOCK -- HELD
LOSE THEIR MINDS, HELD LOSE
THEIR MINDS.
LISA: IT ALL ALWAYS GOES IN THE
DIRECTION OF HURTING
REPUBLICANS.
PETE: IT'S DEMOCRATS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. WITH A LOT OF
POWER WENGING AND NODDING AT
DEMOCRATS IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH
POWER ALL FLOWING IN ONE
PARTICULAR DIRECTION, AND HAY
NEVER COUNTED ON ANY OF US
KNOWING BECAUSE IT'S AN ELITE
GOVERNMENT AGENCY AND A SILICON
VALLEY COMPANY THAT WASN'T
SUPPOSE TO BE TO BOUGHT BY ELON
MUSK.
DAN, REAL QUICK, ON YOUR SHOW
TONIGHT WHAT HAVE YOU GOT?
>> PETE HEGSETH, CHARLIE KIRK,
CHARLIE HURT, I'VE GOT A KILLER
MONOLOGUE, AND PETE GETS TO
JUDGE WHO DID IT BETTER IN
KARAOKE, BRET BAIER OR HILLARY
CLINTON.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL: THAT'LL BE GOOD.
LISA: I SAW THE HILLARY CLINTON
THING, AND I WILL NEVER -- YES.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN, I WANTED TO, LIKE, POUND MY
HEAD AGAINST --
[LAUGHTER]
IT WAS BAD -- AGAINST THE WALL.
PETE: BRET BAIER HAS SURPRISING